Hola Valentina la escena aquí en este
momento puedo decirte que es caótica los
manifestantes varias direcciones
nosotros avanzamos hacia detrás de la
prefectura porque no podíamos respirar
afectados por esos epimógenos que
repentinamente comenzaron a lanzar
agentes de la policía grupos de personas
desesperados en Fuentes en dispensadores
de agua corriente lavándose nuestro con
los ojos irritados y nadie comprende Por
qué la policía lanzó esa especie de
ofensiva contra la marcha que avanzaba
de forma ciertamente determinante pero
eh
quedan algunas personas en los
alrededores Eso sí pero esa es la
situación en este momento aquí en ante